hello Oslo super happy to be here again
my name is Oscar dudich and we'll try to
have some fun with event sourcing today
so let's meet our friends the actors of
today's talk so it's Maurice Kate and
Roy because we will be telling the story
about the support team and of course
users
unfortunately we have users in our
applications
and I could probably finish this story
with this slide because that's how it's
usually ending up but but we will try to
do a bit more
so let's try to discuss like the
classical flow that we could see in the
support ticket on or in like
professional terminology incident
so the first thing that should happen is
of course that customer registered and
after that immediately that person tries
to to lock the insane end like you know
something is not working or they believe
that it's not working doesn't matter
because we need to still fix it the next
step is like to select like in Immortal
combat Maurice or Roy
um to handle the ticket so that's
usually the person that is responsible
for investigating that Stuff
Etc
then incident has to be prioritized and
categorized so it's quite important at
least for the user to see that we are
doing something with the ticket but
Jokes Aside the prioritization is
usually connected directly to SLA and
SLO so this is really important because
from now on when we do it then the time
is ticking tick tick tick tick tick
right
so then agent responds to the uh to the
customer usually it's of course have you
tried to turn it off and on again and
then hope that that will resolve the
issue but usually it's not so then the
customer is trying to answer us and this
discussion usually is going for quite
long there is quite long exchange of the
conversation those other events like the
might also happen so for example at
first of course client tells that this
is super critical then it might appear
that just the color has changed so we
might prioritize that ticket or
initially it was looking like a
small bug but it appeared that it's much
more severe so we know all the history
it's not fully linear but that's the
happy path and then once we find the
issue and we believe that it's resolved
and we should tell the user and pass
that information Mark the ticket as
resolved and after that the of course
user should acknowledge the resolution
because it's not like that that we can
say it's working for us I mean we can
say that but it doesn't matter much so
after the client is agreeing on our
resolution then we can finally close the
issue
and if we have a look on this story and
all those
um orange sticky notes then those are
events so those are facts that happened
in our system so they can build some
storytelling because events by their
nature are immutable because what has
seen cannot be unseen what has happened
has happened they gather a specific
business information because as you see
the events even they are touching the
single specific incident they are
gathering a specific fact that occurred
so of course we could do like events
like incident updated incident deleted
but then we will be doing crowd sourcing
which might be a good idea for a talk
but not today
so events usually are ordered in a
sequence of appearance because this is
like a more a model
and like a design so how all of the
events that could happen in our system
but usually
the things are happening in the specific
sequence so once we found out that for
example incident locked then we assigned
agent then agent respondent and after
that prioritized the ticket and we might
have much much more incidents and each
of them will have its own even stream
because we can think about even stream
as a history of specific object specific
thing so if we make a parallel to our
classical approach then even stream
would be like a record in the relational
database but instead of just keeping the
current state we are keeping the whole
history so even stream in other words is
a ID of our entity
plus everything that has happened
and because of that as I mentioned this
is quite powerful because we have a
granular information and precise
information about what has happened to
in our system and if you ask your
business how much data would they need
then they will force to tell you
everything so even sourcing for them
it's an easy buy-in if we explain it
like that
and for us
even sourcing means that we have much
better Diagnostic and much better
understanding of what's going on in
theory we could just take this specific
even stream from our test environment or
maybe even from production and debug it
and see precisely where something was
broken
and how then make the decision to fix it
so it's giving us the tools for us as
detectives on finding out what was wrong
and that's how we are coming to event
sourcing
because event sourcing is uh we could
say about even sourcing that it's a
simple storage pattern so we could
compare that to document approach or
relational approach but in our case
events are our state this is the name
even sourcing because events are our
source of true and surprisingly even
sourcing is not so revolutionary as it
may seem
so we still need to get some specific
requests for example from the API like
here resolve incident
the only difference from like a cradish
approach is that this request only in
other words command needs to have a
specific business intention because if
we don't know the specific business
intention so the operation that we will
be doing then how can we register a
proper business event
and then that's the first part that is
different from the classical approach
because we are still getting the state
from from event store but here we are
getting all the events that had happened
for the specific object so
instead of just getting a single row
then we are getting all the events and
after that we need to build the current
representation of our state because it's
not like in even sourcing we don't need
to try to understand what's the current
state in even sourcing terminology it's
to be precise State at the certain point
in time so what we are doing we are just
usually building a default object it
might be default Constructor and then
applying each event after one another
and getting the current state so see
when we are logging the incident then
the status is pending we don't know
who's assigned and whether there was a
response and when we assigned I agent
then we are only updating information
about this agent because events are
granular
and
even after event is like a for each
statement
we are getting the current state and
here no difference no difference from
the regular approach we still need to do
all the validation we still need to do
the business Logic on our current state
so this part is precisely the same as
you would do in your classical approach
and this is the second thing the second
difference is that instead of
overriding our whole state we're just
appending new information new fact of
what has happened the result of our
business operation
and it's ending up as in the end of our
event stream because as I mentioned it's
the ordered sequence of events because
we need to know what was the spec how
how those events occurred
and now I already mentioned I think once
or twice even store so let's maybe
briefly discuss how to store those
events are there any people that were a
year ago on my talk how to build event
store
yeah I see at least five
so you probably know that already so
this is like a happening because the
year ago I was showing how to build even
store and then I concluded that you can
do it for fun but you should not be
doing that on production and today I
will show you some maybe system so
Martin that will allows you to use it on
production
and this few words about me together
with Jeremy we are creating Martin and
so-called Critter stack so we have
Wolverine we have weasel so everything
that helps you to build uh
application without much boilerplate and
focus on what on the business
Etc and Martin which is the example of
the event store is using postgres as a
event store and Martin also allows to
use
postgres as a document database and my
experience is also quite broad because I
was also working at even store DB so I
know most of the popular
approach in a nutshell that that's
enough about me let's see how even store
is working internally
so surprisingly
and from what is usually explained in
the Articles of course if someone is
telling you that Kafka is an investor
it's not so let's make it clear and move
on
so because logically even stores are key
value databases you can think about them
logically like a key value stores where
key as I mentioned is the ID of the
record and value
is the sequence of event
and once we realize that then many
things will start to become much simpler
because when I'm discussing with people
then I'm usually getting answer
questions like okay but what if the
stream will be extremely wrong then the
answer I can say is another question
like if you are using mongodb and you
put huge collection inside your document
then will it be fast no it won't but the
answer is just don't do that just model
stuff differently and that's the same
answer for even sourcing then another
answer another question is it are there
any performance issues I mean if even
stores are databases then obviously
databases might may have the performance
issues that's undeniable but the answer
to
have the good performance is to properly
model and land the learn the details and
about how to model stuff in this
specific Paradigm so in even sourcing
the most important is to keep streams
long short leaving so to not have a lot
of streams but in other words if we
think that it's just a key value store
then
I think that it's it's much easier but
technically
and it's also for relational databases
because in relational databases actually
in internally are also happened only
stores where the up and Only store is
the transaction log or write a headlock
and even stores is for example Martin is
like a really long story long table with
a lot of events so we have currently a
single table with with all the events
which might sound scary but to be true
databases are pretty good in indexing
and if we keep stream ID as a index and
as a reference then searching even for
millions of Records is super easy but
Martin has also other capabilities so we
have like a multi-tenancy per database
so we can share the data
postgres allows to add more stuff like
built-in partitioning so there is a lot
of things that
we can improve because even stores are
really simple databases because they
have they should have only two
operations like by their nature so at
opens new events at the end of a stream
and read all events from stream
and this Simplicity allows optimization
and of course there are other even other
stores not all stores are using some
other database underneath for example
even store DB is a database that was
natively built for events so it's just
storing files on disk like database
right
but we will focus today on Martin but
most of the staff and most of the code
that you will see soon will be also
applicable for other event stores
so this is the table that I mentioned or
actually a bit simplified version of it
because what's the most important is
that what we may notice is that data so
our events are built from two types of
data one is the metadata and metadata
are those all of those fields that are
that we could find that are the same for
all the events so for example all the
events should have ID all the events
should be linked to specific stream
those the stream ID all the events
should have the version so the sequence
in which they were appended to stream
they should have the type so what do
they represent and they should also have
data and this is also the place why we
selected postgres or actually Jeremy
selected
at that time because postgres has great
Json capabilities it's uh I know that
there are lies bigger lies and
benchmarks but I saw benchmarks that
were even showing that Mark postgres is
even faster in Json processing than for
example mongodb
so why postgres I already said few
things but in general postgres is cool
it's a rock solid database and it's also
becoming the fact of Standards like a
lingua Franca of all the databases like
for example cockroach Aurora DB Azure
Cosmos for postgres all of them are
adding dialect and using their engine to
build other types of databases and also
based on my research it's not confirmed
but what I saw like for example AWS
document the bdb is built on top of it's
just a syntactic sugar on top of
postgres
and postgres gives us strong consistency
which is quite important and this is the
thing that most of the even stores don't
have at least on the root model side on
the right side most of them have that
and
of course
great power gives
comes with the great responsibility so
just because we are giving you option to
use like a unit of work up and events to
multiple streams at the same time and
build projections in the same
transaction it doesn't mean that you
have to do it right this is just an
option because in Martin we have two
rules one is the we take pull requests
and the other rule is that we won't tell
you how to live
so we are trying to not get if you were
yesterday on Jeremy talk then we are
really against having the lowest common
denominator so if we decided and believe
that postgres is a good option to to use
as even store then we are not going to
just cut the features because we are too
opinionated
if if we thought that for example we
should not allow strong consistency for
it models then we could use other
database or build other and that would
be fine but yeah in general we are
trying to be pragmatic
and I think that if I'm not mistaken
then this is a dotnet conference then it
would be nice to see some code not only
hearing my uh talking
so let's have a look how we could how we
could Define events in our system so the
story of
Maurice and Roy
so
um events
as I mentioned they all contain a
specific information that is
characteristic for them so for example
when we are logging incident then we
have all the information about the
customer about the description
Etc but then if we are categorizing or
prioritizing uh the incident then we
don't need to repeat ourselves because
we already logged that and remember
because we will be getting all the
events then we will have all the
information that we need
so they should be really focused about
the information that we are storing
the thing
that careful viewer could see is that
all of them have the incident ID an
incident ID is also the our stream ID so
that's also showing that all the events
are correlated by that so this is the
thing that we could repeat but in
general I'm just using records because
they are immutable and it's also the the
events are also a nice way to build a
business representation in our code
because if we are using such concise
syntax then this is also something that
we could show even to our business of
course not without our explanation but
we can use it as a node and just showing
them this is what we have and they
should understand that
what's more if we are discussing with
business then it will be also easier for
us to move it and understand back and
forth
an interesting thing is that business
understand even better than us because
we usually think about events like Mouse
button click Etc when my product owner
that was totally not technical person
after working like month with us
he was telling that like hey then let's
just add this event and publish that and
they will get this event and listen and
go forward so yeah we say like Camille
you probably spent too much time with us
but
yeah
um nevertheless let's move on so we have
our events which are records so
immutable State Etc and I also added
some some uh
that I will use also for to Define our
current state
because our current state so the
incident
it's just an interpretation of of our
events and we should still have it and
the really great part about the about
even sourcing is that we can keep our
business logic you will see that in a
moment really uh tiny because
in traditional approach we have right
model what we write is what we read then
we we need to keep all of the
information like notes like description
Etc even though we don't need that
actually for our business logic we are
not making any ifs about the description
we are not checking notes Etc if our
only rule is that we can
um for example
um resolve ticket only if we have all of
the questions from the customer when
answered then maybe we could just keep
this billion flag and maybe some status
just to double check our logic you will
see that in a minute so it's not that we
all of the information see there is
quite a lot that we are logging it's not
that we need to repeat everything in in
our current state
so to note just make it
uh talking let's let me show you that
[Music]
um
so let's add some commands and comments
usually are in most cases one to one two
events that's not always that this is
not a hard rule more like a fun rule so
if we need to capture those business
logic and the business facts then we
also need to have the business comments
like lock incident categorize incident
and the main difference is that command
is an intention to do something it
doesn't mean that it will be it will
happen because it it should be validated
it should be the business logic needs to
be run Etc and even is something that is
that has already happened and that's
also why we should embrace that in our
naming so events should be named in a
past tense and comments in the in the
regular
so this those are our commands and let's
have a look how our business logic could
look like
so let's build a simple service
and the simple service
has the static methods nothing injected
no repositories Jeremy would kill me if
I added them
so this is a really
someone may say that this is a
functional programming but in my opinion
it's just a simple code so what we have
here is that for the first Common log
incident there is no state so we just
have command and we are producing new
event
if we are wanting to categorize event
then we need to ensure that this
incident wasn't close already and then
we are just setting up the new event and
the same pattern happens for all the
cases there is nothing fancy I think the
most the fences is this resolution so we
are just making sure that this incident
wasn't resolved already and that all the
questions were answered
and this is also really powerful because
many people is telling me that even
sourcing is hard to test like what can
be easier to test than just pure
function that just takes common state
and get event it's super predictable and
really easy to maintain so even though
even sourcing is really connected with
the DDD Community then it's not that you
need to use the all the Tactical
patterns if you don't want to like
aggregate maybe it's not needed if you
have just a simple logic I'm not sure if
I can even name it business logic but if
you have something like that then why to
try to make stuff harder and I'm also
showing you that to prove that even
sourcing is not that scary and not that
hard to implement because many people
are claiming that yeah it's super hard
but it's not it's uh there there is a
lot of things that you can find on
internet that are terribly wrong but
this is uh I mean surprise
but this is this is even sourcing in a
nutshell
but okay I show you events I will show
you how to run the business logic
how to return events from the business
logic
let's have a look
on the part that is one of the most
important so how to build our current
state from those events
and
let me
let me add again
I mean I promise you live coding and
it's live copy and pasting sorry for
that
I'm a such a liar
yeah at least on even sourcing I'm not
lying of course
um so yeah so I just extended our entity
with the information on how we should
update our current state based on based
on events that we are receiving so those
are functions that will be run in like a
for each statement and what you see here
it's Martin convention so you might have
create method which will take the event
because that assumes that this is the
first event from the stream and it
should return the new state and apply
our methods that are taking the the
event and are acting on the current
state so this I'm using the records the
record syntax that allows us to say like
what has changed so for example if agent
result responded to incident then we are
marking that he answered all the
questions optimistically
if customer responded then we are
marking that node there is something to
answer and for the events like even
incidents resolved resolution
acknowledge incident close then we are
just updating the current status
so this is simple stuff and if we run
all of those methods on the sequence of
events that we are getting from our
event store then we can just build the
current state and we are doing that
everything in memory so if our stream is
not too long then it will take like a
milliseconds of course you don't need to
use records Martin also allows to just
use regular classes structures whatever
you want
um this is just the thing that I really
like because if you look on this code
then it's also a documentation so that's
something that we don't want to write
and if we use event sourcing then we
don't need to write it but we still
accidentally will have it which is I
think a big benefit of that
so okay
we have our events we know how to build
the state from them we have our
so-called business logic
but
let's go further because this could be
good for a conference talk maybe but
let's make it a bit more
production ready
as I promised
so let's add some new class again no
repository Jeremy
so let's think how having our aggregate
entity whatever we call it how to store
the information in in our event store so
Martin has the main class like you can
think like DB context we have document
session and document session have uh
events property on which you you will be
acting when interacting with the event
store part so the basic method for
creating news team is not surprisingly
start stream and what we are providing
there is an event
and ID of our stream and this is really
important because as I said in Martin we
are not telling you how to live that's
quite one of the rare things most of
Event Source do not allow to to happen
to more than one stream which is
probably good idea
to not to restrict that because people
are doing crazy stuff
surprise
but we allowed that so this is like our
unit of work so you can update more than
that and that will be really important
when we get to the second part of the
talk
and then we can also Define a really
simple method on updating our state so
it looks a bit scary because it has five
parameters but it's not that
so the first thing that we will be doing
is calling aggregate stream async an
aggregate stream async is a Martin
method that what it does we are
providing them a stream ID Martin will
load all the events from the stream then
it will run internally for each and call
by convention store methods either
create or apply and return to you the
current state
if the
um
if the stream didn't exist then of
course it will return null so that's why
we need to verify that and we can
provide a function and function will be
our business logic so those methods that
you already saw we can provide here and
after we will be getting event
and Martin also allows you to use the
optimistic concurrency to get the full
certainty that you are making decisions
uh based on the current state so save
changes internally when it called it
opens the new transaction and either all
the changes will be applied the event
will be appended and as you see further
on
the
read models will be updated or none so
that's that's really important thing
here
um so if we just to make sure that
everyone is aligned with the optimistic
concurrency so it's not a specific for
even sourcing so if you don't plan to
use event sourcing and just sitting
because you are kind a person to not go
out then this is the stuff that you can
take to your project so optimistic
concurrency is a thing that help you to
ensure that you no one updated your
state in the meantime so then the first
thing that we are doing when getting the
data is we also getting the current
version of the state so in even sourcing
that will be probably equal to the
number of events in the Stream
then when we are making some decision
really important decision
then we can pass this version so this
version that we are saying that based on
my knowledge you should have like three
events in the Stream
and if database see that yeah okay I
have three events you you are fine to go
then it it will take the event write it
and then the other person that reads the
events from the database and also have
the free events then if it provides also
the same version that they got then
database will say nope
so this is really important because
transaction plus business logic plus
optimistic concurrency give us full
certainty that we are really have the
strong consistency and no one in the
meantime change anything so in the
internet you can find a lot of resources
claiming that even sourcing uh is you
will have always eventual consistency
that's not correct all of the major even
stores that I know so Martin even store
DB axon
Etc all of them on the right side have
strong consistency they support either
transactions like Martin or atomicity as
even store DB
so this is really important because
that's just a myth because people are
using messaging queues as even stores
and then they are thinking that well I
don't have strong consistency okay you
don't that's correct
um so
just to show you because this is Method
this is almost fine because it at least
shows us what's happening but Martin
also gave us a shortened version of that
as I said we are trying to reduce the
boilerplate and allow you to focus on
the business
so we also have the method maybe the
name is not great but it's how it is
naming is hard so right to aggregate
what it does we provide the ID the
version and if it notices during the
reading that the version is already not
the same as the version from the stream
then it will fail fast so you
it's like a mechanical sympathy
and then we have more option around the
stream so we can get the aggregate which
is our current state and we can for
example up into one event happen more
than one event so this will just
encapsulate this whole logic so
just a synthetic sugar on top of what I
show you but still I think it's quite
nice
um
so maybe
as we have some time then let's try to
make a really simple application
I'm always joking probably some of you
already heard that that in front end
world the single page application were
fashionable and still are and in.net
nowadays we can build a single file
application
so that's almost what we will be doing
so Martin also give a help to in this
super pattern which is a single file
application and Martin provides also
capabilities to help you to set up so
you won't need to do yours bring your
own
dependency injection and write
everything from scratch so we have some
extension methods like the add Martin is
the main one which allows you to for
example configure options like the
schemas of the database the connection
string obviously we are also supporting
because we are using Json and we provide
by default Newton soft because system
takes Json is not fully
in full parity with the Newton soft but
you can also use it like here
and we also have some option this we
will discuss later on
and just maybe add some
yeah okay and then let's have a look how
our endpoint could look like
so our single page application
we could use the latest greatest syntax
from the dot net word
so for example if we are logging new
incident then we are taking request
and we are calling this extension method
that we just defined the at method which
will just
take the result of the handle method and
handle method is what you already know
so this simple service method so like a
Simple Pure function
and the same pattern goes further on so
if we want to use optimistic concurrency
and you want
then for example we can take the
expected version from etac
and we can provide that to our get an
update parameter and we need to provide
some function we will have the state and
we can run on this state our handle
method which is again
the method that we just defined so
simple stuff no need for hundreds of
layers Etc
it's almost like a serverless approach
So speaking about serverless
I was working in a node.js project when
we were building a serverless on AWS
and I counted seven layers just to get
to the business logic
so that's not something that you would
necessarily would like to
that's something that I would really
discourage if you have a simple
application and if you don't need to
have so many abstractions start simple
then add abstractions when you need them
and that's also something that we enable
of course if you like clean architecture
if you'd like controllers
Etc that's totally fine as as I
mentioned we are we won't tell you how
to leave Martin can be used like that
but I'm just showing potentially simpler
way
so
does anyone know web page there I fix it
it's surprisingly it's still open and
people are still sending such photos
there I was really digging that page in
my high school I just checked and those
are quite recent photos from there and
these photos are showing uh like how
people are interpreting word all right
see for that guy this is perfectly
solved
you can for this guy the same and this
is even better right because you don't
you not only have the buy cycle but you
can also do the barbecue sounds good and
um why am i showing that to you not only
just to tell that this is how we are
fixing our stuff also if someone took a
picture then it would be more or less
like that but Jokes Aside
I want to tell you about the projections
because projections is one of the even
sourcing secret source and projections
are just a different interpretation of
the same thing so for those guys
everything works as it should it's great
for most of you hearing your laughs I
assume that probably not luckily
I mean don't take that home as a
as a lesson from the from this talk and
not try to do barbecue like that but
projection are just inter different
interpretation of the same thing so for
example if we have the incident resolve
or incident closed it's quite often when
we are telling user works for me or
cannot reproduce that and for us this
case close we are happy and the same
fact for the business is like nope
that's not true and I'm also showing
another example like a football match or
soccer for Jeremy
when you have two teams and one team win
and the other lose then this is a fact
right this is a fact that just happened
but for the fans of the one team this
will be totally sad experience and for
other extremely happy so
why am i showing you this meta
information because that's also
something that we can use in event
sourcing and in general in an even
driven world because if we take a
sequence of events the specific sequence
of event then each of us will be
interpreting that differently and what's
more we can fine tune that
interpretation for our needs so for
example for the purely technical
diagnostic we can interpret that totally
different than for the business and for
the users like for example even this
incident usually we have those in
internal nodes like when we are just
bashing our users and then hoping that
we selected properly that it should be
internal right
and projections because
that was one of the hardest part for me
when I was learning even sourcing
because I understood pretty well the
right concept yeah we are getting events
building the state running business
logic storing new events and that's fine
because most of our business uh
objects don't have a lot of operations
so they won't have a lot of events but I
thought like okay but how do we get the
list of for example all incidents then
should we load all events that wouldn't
be performant for sure
because whatever I claim that it's okay
to load more events than reading one row
will be always faster than reading three
rows
so in
even sourcing in even driven
architecture projections can be used to
create the read models and we can take
the database like a database table and
take our events for example incident
locked and apply them one by one
updating the specific row
one after another so if we have incident
lock then we can add new row into our
database when we have agent responded to
incident then we are updating for
example nodes count
and when we have the incident resolve
then then we are changing the Status and
that may look a bit redundant
but if you notice then we are just
updating the subset of the data so
knowing this business information and
what has happened give us also
possibility to make the performance
optimization because we can just update
what we need for example if we are not
using postgres but we we would like to
build a read model to mongodb then
mongodb has this great Atomic operations
that we can update just a subset of
records and that's what we can do here
and really powerful thing is that a
single event so for example agent was
assigned to incident will potentially
update multiple read models so for
example agent assignment incidents some
incident dashboard maybe it will also
send some notification and this is only
a various interpretations and various
operations that will happen after this
specific fact was observed
so this is really powerful because it
also cuts the cognitive load as you saw
the business logic if we removed all the
fluffiness of all the descriptions all
the data that we don't need for business
logic is quite simple and then in even
sourcing we can focus first how to
capture our events so the business facts
the best and then we can think how to
use them so for example in the
projections
and as I mentioned we can also have the
strong consistency on right side on read
side that's what Martin allows you to
have
so we can have the unit of work and when
we are pending events then we can grab
all the projections that can handle this
event
and just store it in the same
transaction because why not I mean of
course there is a performance
potentially degradation because one
event May update like potentially 5 10
or how how many read models we create so
we need to be extremely careful on that
if we are fine with the eventual
consistency then it's probably better to
use async projections which we also have
in our case it's called async demon it
sounds seriously like a really serious
and uh feature
but yeah as you said it's like also what
Aaron told on yesterday talk it's about
optionality so giving us more option
more more stuff that we can do and
fine-tune to our use case
so let's see how the projections could
look like in Martin
and let's go and Define the incident
details maybe let's have a look first on
our incident
just to show you
see this is our interpretation and it's
also projection but projection made in
memory
um so this is really simple only
information that we need for our
business logic but for our read models
definitely we will need more
because we would like to for example
show users
see
I'm made that simple to copy and paste
and I cannot even do that properly
so incident details is showing all of
the stuff that has happened for for the
specific incident so we have all the
information that we logged in the events
so when we categorize event and the
category the priority the all the nodes
so all the discussions that were
happening in our case of course the
status customer ID agent ID and so on
and so forth
so this is the interpretation of the
same set of events so as we did for the
incident and Martin also gave you the
possibility to cut the boilerplate code
and we have a set of Base classes for
um for creating grid models so for
example single stream projection what it
does is that
we it will assume that the ID of the
read model is the same as ID of the
Stream
and
even after event when the event was
appended so we called append and we
called save changes then Martin will try
to find do I have a projection that is
registered as inline so to be run in the
same transaction that can handle this
specific event
and in I think version 4 we simplify the
registration so we you can also use the
same conventions that you have for the
right model so you also have the create
and apply methods the only difference is
that they are taking the current state
as a parameter instead of using this but
it's the same stuff so you are just
defining that hey for this specific
event
I would like to update this specific
grid model and this is how you should do
it so simple as that and Martin as the
second part of Martin or actually the
first chronologically is the document
part so you we can use postgres as a
document database where key is the
primary key of the table and the value
is the Json B because we are also using
so think about like building a
on postgres but with the strong
consistency Etc so we are benefiting
actually from that
so you know this is just adding some
notes applying events and here you can
also you don't need to use records in
mutable data you can mutate it's totally
fine because in the end what will it do
it it will at first load the current
state pass it to the method update it
and do the Absurd
so maybe let's have a look on other
[Music]
on other
um
projection so other interpretation of
the same set of events so we can Define
also the incident short info because we
usually have this combination like
details and list View and this is like a
simpler version we don't have all the
nodes we just have the notes count
and some smaller amount of data and we
also can register it like that so we can
have a single stream projection and
Define all the apply methods that will
just take the events as they go apply
them and store
and then what you can do with that if we
get back to the program file so our
single page a single file application
then Martin also gives you possibility
to run link queries so just like in
Entity framework so we can tell that for
example we would like to get all the
short info filter it by the customer ID
and even page it
for getting the incident the details
then we can get it by ID and Martin has
also really a cool feature so if we
because
getting data the serializing Json then
serializing it back to just return to
through ASP it's just potentially too
much allocation that's just redundant so
what we can do is that this method write
by ID and also
write RI that allows you to just stream
directly Json from the postgres so that
cannot be more faster and that's one of
the powerful stuff about the event
sourcing and cqrs that because you know
the usage patterns you know the business
intentions and you know that this won't
be ever modified because you you just
want to return the data then nothing can
be faster than just pure streaming as it
is and you can still use the link if
you'd like to
um
so if you want more
then I will there is more stuff that we
can go like for example
incident history
so if we'd like to Define some human
readable history like an audit log of
our operation sure we can also do that
we have also another Base Class which is
event projection not the greatest name
again but what it does it just do
whatever you want with the events so
bring your own stuff so for example we
are getting events together with the
metadata and for each event we are
adding new documents so new entry and
building a human readable history
and we also can have the multi-stream
projection of course but the last thing
that I would like to show you is that
for example
we could also build based on that
we can build as ultimate custom
projection
that will allow you to for example push
the info push the events to for example
signalr and notify your front-end about
it this is you need to just Implement
eye projection and all of our
projections are also internally
implementing this interface and here you
have a bit more stuff
but
um
it's quite simple so you are taking all
the events and then you might decide to
for example push it to signalr
and a Kafka users
nope
that's cool
actually
but see if you are Kafka user and you
are not luckily but for example service
bus or rabbit then you can also do the
same and implement this pattern the same
way if you'd like to forward your events
so you can write a custom projection
that will be just listening for events
and then calling some specific messaging
system or streaming system
so there are plenty of options that you
might have and just to show you the
finally how the registrations of this
projection looks like
and then let's get back to our
program
and add Martin
so for that
you can have like registration of your
projection where you are passing the
information about
um about your projection and then you
define whether it should be run in the
same transaction so inline or
asynchronously and this is the line that
is running the hosted service that will
be processing that
but in general this is how Martin is
doing this is quite the projection stuff
is really unique for Martin I don't know
other event stores that
probably have that built in
like that but all of those patterns you
can also build on your own like using
given store DB other event stores Etc so
my intention wasn't just to
show how cool Martin is I mean not only
but the same logic see the the same
simple transformation you could apply
and write on your own for any other
messaging system or even store
so summing up I hope that
I managed to show you that even sourcing
is not so scary that it's actually
useful that you might consider using it
in your system
so if you see now blog posts or some
friend will send you the blog post that
has such an image of the even sourcing
or such one then I hope that you will
tell your friend that no no no this is
not event sourcing because even sourcing
is a in a nutshell it's a simple storage
pattern where you are treating events as
your source of true as your state and
each operation starts with loading all
events building the state making
decision and storing them as facts
because events are business facts and
that's really important because that
enables multiple options for your
business if you discuss that with your
business for sure you will see the
blinking guys
and that will also help us because it's
really enhanced diagnostic if we have
some back to track Etc then that will
make our life much much easier
and even stores are not messaging
systems even store logically are a key
value stores where key is the record ID
and the value is the sequence of events
so the history of this object
and physically usually they are
implemented like a huge up and Only log
which give us not only the ordering
guarantee on the stream level but also
Global level
and Martin is a quite unique in this
area because we bring a lot of stuff
like strong consistency if you need that
and we also bringing the projections so
different interpretations of the same
data
and this is really a secret source of
even sourcing
and
I really encourage you to try it
yourself
it's really fun to build it and if I
didn't manage to persuade you then maybe
those sweet Martens will do it
so thank you a lot it was a pleasure I
will be here the whole day also tomorrow
just catch me if you even see that I'm
talking with someone else and you would
like to come and ask me just feel free
to interrupt me
um really open on discussing that all of
that with you so thank you
foreign
[Applause]